gina mcdonald knows a lot about this
subject she's a recovering addict she
was prescribed opioids after surgery and
got addicted like so many other people
have she's now the co-founder of mothers
against drug deaths she joins us tonight
gene thanks so much for coming on so
you've seen every part of this epidemic
too much of it what do you make of these
ads
yes too much but thank you for having me
tucker
um when i first saw these ads i thought
um
to use the word empowerment to me was
ridiculous first of all my drug
addiction
robbed me of my dignity yes my health my
kids my sanity there was no empowerment
in my drug addiction and whether i used
with a friend
or whether i used a clean pipe
it still took me to the depths of hell
so i don't
understand how we're encouraging uh it
sounds like it very much sounds like
encouraging
and empowering people and in the very
bottom and if you notice in the very
bottom left hand corner
an afterthought is
here's how you get help and i don't
understand why they don't lead with that
well sure i mean there's it's the
opposite i mean addiction is the most
degrading thing that can happen to a
person most people have been addicted to
something will tell you they'd rather
have cancer than an addiction so to have
the authorities encouraging addiction i
mean
what does this mean why would they do
that do you have any idea
you know i i'm i'm digging into that and
to me it seems i mean people get paid
it's a big industry right too well
that's right you know very big industry
uh the addiction and and treatment
treatment you know
but we have the same thing in san
francisco we've had posters like this
and and adds like this up for a while
that know your overdose um use with
friends and the pictures they show or
look like people partying and having a
good time
and it you know it it's it's enabling
and they put these posters up and they
hand people foil and they hand people
straws and they hand people pipes
and say we're meeting them where they're
at but they're leaving in them there
it's it's
it's not compassionate to leave someone
on the street
if you gave this advice to your own
children and help them use narcotics you
would have them taken away by family
services correct
absolutely that's what happened to me
right i mean i was in i was in the
middle of a meth induced psychosis
on the street and the police picked me
up
i lost my kids i lost everything they
took me to a mental facility and they
said you can go in here or you can go to
jail and we just aren't doing that
anymore we need to do more of that
i think you're exactly if you really
wanted to save people's lives
and empower and actually empower them
and return them their dignity great gene
mcdonald i appreciate your perspective
and your bravery and saying so thank you
thank you so much tucker
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight